Are you attempting
to break up with me?
(SIGHS) Dude, ATN
Nazi stuff, human furniture,
I just don't really love it,
and I wanna go explore.
Tom. Tom. We're good.
We're good?
This doesn't feel
fucking good, Greg!
It's a little bit like
what if your dog said
it wanted to go and live with
your neighbor instead of you.
This is your trusty pal,
this is the thing you thought
would always be there.
So, when that goes away,
it rocks you a bit.
-(TOM SCREAMS)
-GREG: Stop! Stop! Ow!
Stop pelting me!
JESSE: Hopefully, we didn't go
full method on the throwing.
-Security!
-JESSE: But yeah,
he took a bit of
punishment in there.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS,
CONCLUDES) ♪
Rhea Jarell.
And you must be Oedipus Roy.
Uh...
Rhea Jarell is the CEO
of Pierce media,
this more blue-blood,
more well-respected,
also family-owned
media conglomerate.
Stay. Have lunch.
Oh, my tummy is delicate.
We really only eat Pulitzer
over at Pierce.
JESSE: Holly Hunter was
the go-to person
for the Rhea role.
We all felt like she could play
the power and the subtlety.
You know, this character
doesn't embody the same variety
of power that Logan does,
which is kind of the bludgeon;
she's much more
the subtle knife.
The family knows
what you're after,
and they're not interested.
And what am I after?
You're playing your favorite
tune again, no?
Only this time I take it
some genius banker's
convinced you that
the only way
to keep the jackals out
is to leverage yourself
until you're too big
to take down.
There's not many people
who Logan finds interesting,
but someone like that
is interesting to him,
and so there seems like
a possibility of
a certain mutual regard
between them,
even if they come from
slightly different places.
On behalf of the Pierce family
and the media organization
that it's privately owned
for 150 years,
the message would be a typically
balanced, nuanced,
and objective "fuck off."
Very nuanced.
Logan's like a shark that
always keeps moving forward.
Twenty-one billion dollars.
The thing is, it's an emotional
matter for the Pierces.
-21.5.
-SHIV ROY: Kendall.
Is he allowed to just say
numbers?
It doesn't fit with Logan's
character to be defeated,
so in some ways,
he can't be.
Well done, son. Good work.
♪ (MUSIC PLAYS, CONCLUDES) ♪